[Music]
now come on we've all got a sweet tooth
so i take you looking for a perfect
dessert
that's beautiful delicious and so quick
well let me tell you my rhubarb tart is
gonna really up the ante on your typical
dessert especially at home
but i do have a confession to make
it may take a little longer than 10
minutes
oscar pan down please
puff pastry
this is store-bought puff pastry don't
be worried about it it's really good and
so simple we have a little puff
basically short crust is equally as good
beautiful marzipan and that's the sort
of fast-track substitute to make in a
frangipane
lovely false rhubarb delicious from
yorkshire
blood orange a little bit of honey
mascarpone cream cheese almonds a little
bit of butter and egg and that should
make the perfect heart right let's have
10 minutes
maybe plus one or two on the clock
please right first off take the back
your knife
and just go down
about a centimeter in
and what this does
is sort of literally
starts to lift up the outside of these
little rolled parcels
of puff pastry now like i said
this was store-bought and all we're
doing here is creating this little line
okay and that will give you a sort of
edge it'll give you a lift and so when
it cooks in the oven it sort of creates
this little moat
that keeps the juices in
and more importantly
okay
it helps to create an edge on your tart
okay
now i can go fancy and go along
and sort of lift that up but that there
is fine now the rhubarb
okay look at the
size of that gap there
and slice there
through okay
and literally one stick
per tart
should be sufficient
and the beauty of these is that they are
so sort of
cheap
cheerful you see rhubarb
everywhere especially across the summer
and boy is it in abundance
i don't like peeling it because all that
flavor is in the skin growing up
with rhubarb it was literally rhubarb
crumble rhubarb pie you name it we had
it now line these up
from there
take your brush
and just lightly egg wash the outside of
that puff pastry
that's gonna give it okay a really nice
glaze
okay and you'll see the difference
especially
when they cook in ten minutes okay
it's quite thin the pastry it's already
rolled out that's how practical and easy
these tarts are
they're very easy for a sunday brunch
sort of pick me up
dessert straight after pretty impressive
when they come out
now from there
glaze egg yolk only that gives that sort
of royal
texture
to the puff pastry
now with a master pan
take your box grater
get the small side of the grater and
just go straight down be careful it does
stick
i've frozen
my
marzipan and so it's like a solid block
and that helps to sort of create
a lot easier shards okay and you'll see
as i start to grate it
it sort of crumbles quickly which is
nice
there that's what we want and all we do
now is just get that very quickly and
sort of line the top of that okay
from there
spread that out
it almost looks like sort of grated
cheese but what it does it gives a
really nice sort of grate
and it sort of
coats
the tart usually break it up
so it doesn't clump together
again
one more
and move it around
so it separates
nice
now look
sprinkle that gun down
and lightly put it on there
so let's take two
i don't mind going over 10 minutes
especially for a dessert
and let's be honest it's very hard to
get a seriously good dessert done in 10
minutes but this is gonna be close let
me tell you
from there
marzipan
favorite little bit of sugar
sprinkle sugar over there
you can see we're starting to layer up
that puff pastry
like i said short crust is just as good
but puff pastry gives it a bit of
lightness
now for the rhubarb
right
start layering
these in now
okay
and just run down the side
and make sure it sits
within that box
okay beautiful
when they get a little bit thick just
open them up
and do the big ones
in half
down
now the secret behind
the marzipan
is to make sure
we've got that wonderful
sweetness against the tartness of the
rhubarb and just sit that on there a
little bit of sugar
on top
and then into the oven
and watch
the glaze
take off the sugar goes on top and that
gives that nice sort of sweet sugary
effect especially the tartness for the
rhubarb
in we go
and literally
they're gonna take about eight or nine
minutes
right they're in how do we feel that
time let's get those almonds and let's
make the delays pan on for the almonds
okay i want to toast these almonds
they're so tasty when you toast them but
i want to make them a little bit more
sort of extra special dry pan
okay flatten them out and literally just
lightly season them so it's sort of
almost like a sort of toasted salty
almond that sits on top
in this pan we're going to make a
a beautiful glaze
the secret here is start off with a bit
of honey okay
and then we use that blood orange
and this will really help
for a nice glaze to go
on the
top of that rhubarb so bring that honey
to the boil
okay
squeeze squeeze squeeze
beautiful
honey and blood orange glaze that goes
on top of the rhubarb sits brilliantly
okay
from there
i'm going to get my zest
on my blood orange
that goes in
and then we're going to sort of almost
flavor that with the actual blood orange
little segments
here i've got my mascarpone cream cheese
which gives that nice sort of added
silky finish to that rhubarb tart
okay
in in in
now
and turn that round
take all those bits out there look at
that beautiful flavor
nice
almonds get nice and toasted and with
the salt on there they sort of they sort
of smell almost like a sort of salted
almond really nice flavor
from there
top and tail
find the base
find the top
to very carefully go around
and literally
take off that pip
now
tarts from the oven
the color
of these blood oranges are useful
almonds
look at that now
beautiful
beautiful
onto a plate
hello please
seven minutes gone
old ones come out
and then look from here continue going
all the way around
and look
i'm gonna do this now over that
turn that upside down
now
it's unfair to be penalized for the time
in the oven but the actual prep time
trust me
is less
than 10 minutes take these little
segments off
go in
is these little sort of
guided segments
goes in i want half the juice in there
okay
and half the juice in the mascarpone
cream cheese look at the color of that
so beautiful
now wash your hands
check my tarts
she's starting to rise
she's starting to rise
from there give that a little beat
then look
a little bit of juice
we've got that really nice zest
it's a lovely way of finishing
a dessert
it's so good
we'll put a little bit more of my zest
in there that helps to color the cream
okay and so we've got the nice tightness
of the mascarpone
and then we've got the beautiful
vibrant glaze blood orange glaze that
sits on top of that rhubarb
it gives that nice sort of sweetness to
the tartness of that rhubarb shake all
that in there
beautiful
nice mix mix mix and that's ready i'm
going to cornell that on the side of the
plate
using a really nice hot spoon
so we can lift this thing up
right
time for a cup of tea while i wait for
my tarts
this is the worst bit about being a chef
waiting
yes
right
now
take a look at these babies
come on
60 seconds little glaze a little glaze
little glaze little glaze
here we go so take that glaze
over use the back of the spoon and glaze
boy they smell delicious
honestly even cold they're
delicious
little segments in there
[Music]
and then
how do we lift that how do we literally
just
yes yes yes stop rushing me and then
from there look
lift that up let's use this one here
first
yes
a beautiful
amazing rhubarb tart
done
in 12 minutes
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsey and
10 cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're going to come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck